Okay.
During my last deployment to Iraq in 2006 one of the first things we did was a
series of operations on the eastern side of Ramadi.
In order to execute these operations,
we took a majority of the seals to Camp Corregidor home with the first of the
five oh six band of brothers on the edge of the [inaudible] district of mirror
of Ramadi.
Camp Corregidor was like Ford Apocalypse.
They received mortar fire RPGs and small arms fire daily.
The barracks were an old partially blown out building with sandbags in the
windows,
dirt floors and no air conditioning.
There were no showers.
It was hard living.
As far as the fighting Charlie company from the first of the five Oh six who who
we were set to work with had suffered almost 40 casualties in the time they had
been in Ramadi and had gone from a fighting force of 140 to just over a hundred
Charlie company loved having seals with them after the first operation they
conducted with seals.
The company commander told his battalion CEO he wanted seals with him on every
mission to help keep his men alive.
As we continued these initial operations into the melodic district,
there were heavy firefights,
many dead enemy and multiple coalition casualties.
It was intense,
sustained combat.
Many would have considered camp Corregidor and eastern Ramadi to be hell on
earth,
but I knew it was exactly where seals belonged.
We soon completed that first run of missions and headed back to our main camp.
When we got there,
I told one of the platoon commanders,
I wanted him to select guys to form a seven man squad to take back to Camp
Corregidor,
but he told me he didn't want to just pick guys.
He thought that some guys might not want to go back to Corregidor due to the
hard living conditions,
the tough fighting and the high rate of casualties.
That sounded reasonable to me.
So I mustered the whole troop in the planning space.
I explained to them that we were sending a squad to Corregidor permanently
because the army is in a tough fight and suffering heavy casualties and that as
Americans,
as servicemen and as frogman,
we can not sit on the sidelines is that happens.
If there's a fight,
we need to be in it.
I wrote on the Dry Erase Board Camp Corregidor volunteers and I said to this
pack of seals,
if you want to go over to Corregidor,
if you want to volunteer to be in the area with the worst living conditions,
with the hardest fighting and with the highest chances of getting hurt or killed
the,
go ahead and write your name up on that board and then I walked out of the room
a short while later I came back in and I looked at the list on the board.
It was filled,
in fact,
every single seal to a man had written his name on that board.
Yes,
every man had volunteered to go forward
into that raging storm
and that is who we are.
That is what we joined the seal teams for to do what no one else can do.
In the worst areas.
In the worst conditions,
we crave the dirt and sweat and fire and blood.
Let there be no doubt it is in our soul.
It is in our nature.
Sure seals can do any job well,
but it isn't the belly of the beast where we thrive.
I have seen with my own eyes the whole sale slaughter that occurs when seals are
unleashed on the enemy as we were meant to be and it is incredible thing.
It is also a thing of strategic impact areas like Ramadi and solder city,
which after years of complete enemy control become pacified soon after the sort
of overwhelming carnage is wielded by the frog men on the high ground.
This is who we are,
death dealers,
killers,
executioners,
and in being so saviors,
defenders,
warriors,
okay.
Now there are those that say we need to change,
evolve and mature.
They claim that the nature of war has changed,
that it is more complex and demands a more sensitive approach.
I say they are wrong.
War May morph and appear different through the ages and when you live through a
war and you see it up close like we are now,
you may notice complexities that you didn't perceive about the wards you studied
in history class,
but I tell you there is nothing new.
The nature of war has never changed and never will change.
The nature of war is deaf to kill the enemy before he kills you.
The rest is details.
Yeah.
Now of course we can handle the details.
In fact,
seals can excel at all of them.
Gathering intelligence,
assembling information,
forming alliances,
rebuilding communities,
training,
protecting,
treating seals can do anything,
but these details can also be done by others.
You don't need to be a seal to conduct those activities.
I say send seals forward into the violent Frey since yields where no one else
can go to do what no one else can do since you the find and butcher our enemies,
soulless masses and leave nothing behind but scorched earth and rubbled
buildings.
That is our nature.
As I look at the seal teams today,
I say to you all,
yes,
absolutely evolve.
Get smarter,
better,
faster,
more creative.
Learn to mitigate risk when you can figure out new ways to win.
Attack the enemy in new ways using information and intelligence.
Infiltrate the enemy and turn him against himself.
Evil against evil.
Yeah,
adapt and overcome.
Changing enemy tactics.
By all means,
evolve and get better every day,
every chance you get.
But don't forget the nature of war at.
Don't forget the nature of seals.
Okay?
We must train brutally and without mercy so we can fight the same way brutally
and without mercy.
Our job is to close with and destroy the enemy and we do it better than anyone.
Yes,
our current wars will someday end,
but war indoors before man was war,
waited for him as long as man is,
war will always be always.
And our great nation will always need men to do what is in our nature.
Kill the enemy,
kill him as he sleeps.
Kill him as he plots.
Kill him as he hides.
Kill him as he fights.
That is our nature and that is our solemn duty.
Yeah.
Light the fire.
Take the torch.
Hold it high.
Let it burn bright.
Let it supply
the warmth and light of freedom and liberty for our country men,
but also let the fire incinerate our enemy.
Let the inferno consume everything he is,
everything he ever will be and everything he has ever held sacred.
Okay.
As I walk away from the teams today,
I assure you I will never forget.
I will never forget your service and sacrifice.
I will never forget you,
my fellow seals for getting me here to this day for leading me,
for following me and for watching my back.
I will never forget our fellow soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and marines that are fought and sacrificed so much.
I will never forget those big,
tough frogman and hardcore seals that came before me,
particularly the ones that raised me in the teams and taught me the true way of
the frog man.
And finally,
I will never forget our fallen brothers,
the many seals who have sacrificed their lives for our freedom,
especially Mark Lee,
Mike,
soar and Ryan.
Job of seal team three task unit bruiser who lived and fought and died like
warriors.
I am humbled to serve with you all and I will never forget.
Thank you.
God bless the teams at God bless the United States of America.